chambord et et 2016 un ballet de
véhicules fait des allers et venues aux
abords du château parfois jusqu'à 40
camions par jour des travaux de
terrassement titanesque pour préparer la
plantation de parterre ces jardins
s'étendront sur six hectares et lui
novembre 2016 cette première phase de
travaux terminés le moment est bien
choisi pour accueillir des arbres
beaucoup d'arbres 600 en tout qui
violent les cerisiers accompagné de 800
arbustes
ils viennent de la même plénière en
allemagne pour parfaire le mot gênés it
et du site
la plantation nécessite un travail de
précision digne d'une grande
construction
on est venu poser un arbre entre les
tuteurs on n'a pas fait fausse pour pour
planter l'arbre et c'est le sol autour
de cet arbre qui va monter
progressivement
ça a permis de gagner un temps
considérable sur la plantation de tous
ces arbres l'un imaginé sous louis xiv
avec un dessin réalisé en 1734 ces
jardins ont existé pendant plus de deux
cents ans avant de disparaître au siècle
dernier
ils reprennent vie après un énorme
travail de recherche
quand on a le contrat d'engagement du
jardinier de patar ou le devis
d'entretien du jardin séparé pour que
200 ans après on s'en sert donc on s'en
sert comme ça aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
la chance d'avoir eu ces liquidations de
compter ses paiements et ses deux vies
qui font que toutes ces procédures de la
maison en direct sont des bâtiments du
roi permet donc de trouver des éléments
qui 200 ans 250 à 300 ans après nous
disent tiens mais il s'est passé ça et
qui viennent confirmer ces traces
archéologiques on trouve sur le terrain
en tout ces années de recherche
documentaire et prospection auront été
nécessaires pour aboutir à ce
chef-d'oeuvre